noon graduation at las vegas high school  this morning seniors at las vegas high  had a chance to walk across the stage  and earn their diploma in person the  first ceremony was this morning on the  school's football  field principal ron garzon says it's an  exciting day  especially after such a tough year every  single student that i spoke with  was excited at the prospects of being on  our football field on our campus  where they've created lots of lots of  positive memories  and so to end their high school  tenure on a positive note on a normal  note  celebrating with their closest family  and friends  they are way more than excited  las vegas high also has a second  ceremony for graduation that's tonight  at seven  all across clark county school district  graduations last until  next week